[Musique]
les séries on va tout de suite parlé de
l'eurovision qui va gagner parce que
vous avez vu les représentants
l'eurovision je sais que vous adorez
quand on fait ça on va donner notre avis
sur la chanson d'al-ahmar vous avez la
donne est aussi vous allez dire votre
pronostic est votre avis à quelle place
va terminer allemaal match vous voulez
qu'on écoute votre titre tout de suite
avec plaisir attention c'est parti alma
c'est elle qui va nous représenter
lausanne religion etc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais pourquoi je demande un truc tout
con comme ça après on regarde mais pas
le clip ah oui on fait de la radio de la
télé mais sans déconner quoi c'est très
bon nana est ce que vous convient le
clip alors on sourit à la mousse qu'on
nous promet on regarde le clip ou pas
très bonne et on va où vas tu veux te
demande à mouskouri pour ceux qui la
connaissaient voire même délire faisait
partie c'est moi dis moi que tu m'aimes
fais moi danser
le temps nous reprennent
saison
tu l'avais tout cas
[Musique]
on
et puis un jour
[Musique]
alma bravo j'aime beaucoup alors je vous
le dis tout de suite vous dites ce que
vous voulez mais j'aime beaucoup elle
m'a bien salma déjà merci d'être avec
nous merci de mars avoir très heureuse
d'être très dur nous et vous avez
attachez vos jeux oui pour quel motif
des tâches et des länder il pleut dehors
c'est vrai il pleut dehors vous les
détacher qu'on voulait pas ce que je
vous ai vu survie de tâches et c'est
quelque chose également là une chevelure
tu ne ragondet ce rebond et ajustera
gonda
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça c'est du ragoût baisse les
séries alors vous avez entendu alma est
ce que vous pensez kalma va terminer une
bonne place est ce que vous y croyez
pour l'eurovision
dites moi quelle place vous la voyez est
dit nouveau si chez vous à quelle place
je voyais alma si vous pouvez le faire
ça assez vite tu aurais parce que j'ai
pas non plus que ça à faire matthieu
delormeau
vous la voyez focale ma neuvième sais
pas combien vous êtes content devra
payer 26 participants iliad 43
participants mais 26 à la finale
exactement je connais un petit peu
l'eurovision j'ai travaillé un petit peu
en europe et surtout que la péninsule
ibérique
sam envie de dire ce bon donc voilà donc
sur 26 août à combien vous êtes content
moi j'aimerais vraiment à lui si je suis
je serai très fier c'est une entame et
bien mathieu delormeau vous m'aidiez
absolument pour caler les books mais les
bookmakers 9e actuellement encore au
salut 11e chez les bookmakers abbas
agents lundi non non non non ce matin
c'était 10e tournoi non achat excusez
moi je voyais ont fait jouer alors je
vais vous dire chez les bookmakers via
alma donc 9e exactement emmanuel macron
6e marine le pen
donc je mène à vienne elle est très
jolie ça joue quand même parce que c'est
un produit alors ce et je vais vous lire
et moi qui ne regarde pas les physiques
je suis aussi d'accord
donc voilà petit 1 en revanche je suis
moyennement talent de la chanson et il
ya un truc pardon mais que je pardonne
toujours pas non mais arrêtez je chante
en anglais je le redis je le redis
représente un pays malgré tout on sait
très bien qu'aujourd'hui de ça ne change
rien au résultat donc pourquoi les
foudres de l'anglais ils sont toutes en
anglais tu représentes la france tu es
très belle déjà on va pouvoir ouhlala
ouais excusez moi voilà vous représentez
la france
pourquoi avoir mis de l'envié dans cette
chanson alors on découvre tout le monde
chante en anglais pour aller les
chercher mais monsieur c'est pour ça moi
je voulais garder du français quand même
ma chanson il ya 90 passait bien il ya
quand même un peu de français
la dernière chanson qui a gagné ouais
une chanson qui étaient toutes en
français tout à fait ça
meilleur moment
[Musique]
et alors
ça fait comme un enfant donc voyez pas
on aurait chauffé la traduire n'importe
quelle chanson enfant surnommé la bête
de scène
c'est bien là
[Applaudissements]
excusez moi pour cette petite démo sas
anglo saxonne mais j'avais besoin de
remettre les pendules à zéro et a révélé
arqua free on va on va arrêter la
chanson contemporaine si vous avez
n'hésitez pas c'est un fil rouge deux
ans dément également acheté pmp et on
fait ça alors vous donc mais viennent
donc la vie c'est pas mal ne viennent
que valérie benallou bah oui 10e en
tableau aussi pareil alors que matches
sur 26
oui mais parce que votre votre chanson
en fait elle mérite d'être ré écouter et
donc ceux qui vont la découvrir
peut-être que le vote ou tout de suite
comme ça va être moins évident non mais
c'est vrai que je pense que vous avez
des montres exemple que cette dernière
par exemple qu'il convenait une capture
tout de suite mais après c'est vrai que
les gens qui votent à leur horizon que
j'en pense s'intéressent un peu et
peut-être vont voir les demi-finales
éventuellement vont de checker un peu
sur internet les chansons et je ne sais
pas et de rossi galerie koyama été
composée par nazim oui il ya un grand
compositeur qui avait travaillé avec amy
régal exactement qui avait travaillé à
calmy rey ont j'aime beaucoup son pain
donc l'embrassa non
coué ou net alors on va ré coûté la
chance au bon
[Applaudissements]
non mais parce que je trouve que c'est
pas un hit je trouve que c'est pas un
hit
je trouve que c'est une jolie chanson je
trouve que c'est pas un hit flagrant à
mort alors ça rentre dans la tête au
bout de 2 100e fois n'ont jamais écouté
d'ouvrir ma langue l'eiu d'amir rentrer
immédiatement et soprano aussi fait des
voix là et il ya souvent des là là là où
des sont des choses qui rentrent vous
avez raison quand vous dites qu'ils
parlent pas le français dans beaucoup de
régions du monde et que ce en plus de la
grève tout seul sur scène on n'aura pas
de chorégraphes et souvent il ya des
îles et pas que je passais mes copains
sa fraîcheur en même temps avec plaisir
en même temps je me trompe tout le temps
temps bien dans le secteur rivière et je
serai super content pour vous mais c'est
vrai il avait annoncé françois fillon
président absolue et l'aveyron il avait
annoncé jean lassalle voit là n'ont pas
d'ailleurs je sais je crois qu'ils
cherchent à me joindre jean lassalle et
ben ils peuvent appeler continuent eux
mêmes pendant l'émission dont je sais
que là il à l'affairé comprendre juste
après
jean michel maire alors vous êtes le
plus hostile optimistes trois exactement
troisième parce que j'y crois cette
année elle est très jolie lâche pour
autant contrairement à vous voulez pas
vous n'êtes pas bon contrairement à ce
qu'a dit mathieu chante la chanson la
retient tout de suite moi j'ai entendu
une fois jantes entièrement tenues
données
[Rires]
[Musique]
maintenant que c'est un truc ou en fait
vous chantez comme désarticulé en fait
on comprend mieux comparé mon point fort
alors oui et contrairement à ce que dit
sébastien d'être tout seul c'est pas
gênant comme cheetah murs était tout
seul sur scène conchita quand même les
états c'est un faussaire elle était très
belle côte est avait ensuite j'ai
beaucoup fait la part belle à dire assez
revient très fort j'y crois pas du tout
je pense que si on finit 11e on aura de
la chance parce que pas de corps et je
crois pas trop à la chanson mais vous
êtes un maître loin derrière il serait
tout seul je suis désolé je pense que
c'est un show c'est une très grande
scène censée très difficile
d'appréhender une grande scène tout seul
et je pense que ça va pas fonctionner
excusez moi je file à droite à ce que je
dois à alma maintenant je dois vous dire
que je suis j'y crois à fond ces gens
qui pensent que vous allez terminer dans
les dix premiers
si on va terminer pas dans les dix
premiers je vous le dis voilà encore
[Rires]
faites vous fait des paris avec vos
coups on a plané tard yom
[Rires]
ils ont raison j'en avais combien la
base je veux dire si alma bois dans les
dix premiers doubler nos cachets
suriname et cela dit toussaint avec vous
je m'occupe palme à alma franchement je
vous pourrez me demander si tout ce que
vous voudrez pendant un an
tiens dans les missions qu'ils
commettent votre disque et tous les
jours si je dois faire tout ce que vous
voilà si vous voulez éventuellement que
à vienne je sais pas peut-être de chez
vous les trois peut-être pour non mais
c'est vrai ça qui est un petit peu de
plomberie à faire encaisser
vous me garder et jusque là d'accord
merci c'est gentil de quartier j'invite
pas le rang est d'accord ça m'arrange
parce que je suis pas motorisé joli cul
et moi c'est comme thierry sauf que je
suis beaucoup plus positif que lui moi
je crois je crois que c'est un bon 11 au
milieu je trouve que l'anglais ça me
dérange pas moi qui englobe des ouais
ouais
dans la chanson sûr que ça se marie
moins bien que dans les chansons d'amour
on sent que ça a été rajouté après donc
truck series artificiel par contre je
suis pas daccord plus sur les
chorégraphies déjà des gens qui dansent
dans tous les sens déjà ils ont plus de
voix pour chanter et ce qui compte
aujourd'hui c'est assez nos graphistes
qui va se passer du tout ce qui va se
passer sur et je lui fais confiance pour
ça il y aura aucun danseur derrière rien
ne doit pas voler à des projets sociaux
va pas ce que je vais je connais de
trois personnes dans la danse
non mais l'année dernière on en parle
moyenne lassé de grafite et démantelé
raffy était pas terrible du tout